[Applause]
[Music]
can you imagine if your country had a
whole army dedicated almost exclusively
to defending the official ideology of
the ruling party that is to have two
full armies and one of them basically
being strictly dedicated to defending
the government and the political
structures that control the country and
no we're not even talking about north
korea or even china where by the way the
military is statutorily beholden to the
ruling party and not to the state in
this case we are talking about an old
acquaintance of visualpolitik the
islamic republic of iran a state whose
construction believe me is a kind of
huge brain teaser in itself
[Music]
[Applause]
the iranian state is made up of two
major institutional structures on the
one hand there is the religious
apparatus a structure governed by the
supreme leader the ayatollah which forms
the theocratic part of the state
remember that we are talking about an
islamic republic where religion is at
the pinnacle of power for that reason
the religious apparatus is composed of a
network of institutions that have
immense power within the country and
which answer directly to the supreme
leader and which of course are not
elected by the people the second system
is composed of a president a government
and a parliament that are elected more
or less democratically by the voters
however this second system which is
purely political is placed below the
ayatollah hierarchically in iran the
religious dimension prevails over the
political one
[Music]
well exactly the same is true when we
talk about the security forces one of
the two armies we have mentioned is also
hierarchically superior to the other and
yes the one that is superior is
precisely the one under direct orders of
the ayatollah we are talking about the
islamic revolutionary guards corpse
better known to all of us as the iranian
revolutionary guard now the question
that i am sure many of you are asking at
this very moment is why on earth did
ayatollah khomeini order the creation of
a parallel armed forces if there was
already an army in iran well in a way
the answer is none other than a lack of
trust
when the islamic revolution triumphed in
iran in 1979 the new regime of the
ayatollahs inherited an army which until
its victory was known as the imperial
iranian army and which was created in
1921 by raza shah the father of muhammad
raza parlavi the shah of persia opposed
by the revolution itself the fact is
that the ayatollahs had serious doubts
about the iranian army's fidelity and
loyalty to the islamic revolution and
the new religious leaders who had taken
control so in order to consolidate his
power and prevent a possible coup d'etat
ayatollah khomeini ordered to unify
organize and equip the militias that
were faithful to the revolution and had
participated in the overthrow of the
previous regime and so the iranian
revolutionary guard was born a parallel
army that among other functions also has
the task of keeping the republic's
national army in check in case it ever
gets out of line
[Music]
you could say it's something like the
praetorian guard of the ayatollahs an
army whose main function has nothing to
do with the control of the territory but
with the protection of the revolution
and take notes because we are not
talking about a simple elite unit with a
few thousand troops not at all we are
talking about a gigantic force very
powerful and influential both in the
military field and in the political and
economic sphere what's more it's a force
that just keeps growing and now with the
new conservative government that has
taken power it is back in fashion
iran's new defense minister vows to
build up irgc's military power but how
far do the tentacles of this kind of
parallel army reach what are their
capabilities what is their real
influence on iranian politics and
society and perhaps the most important
question of all what kind of operations
can they carry out listen up
[Music]
the ayatollah's praetorian guard
as we have already told you iran is one
of the few countries or perhaps the only
one with two independent armed forces on
the one hand there is the army of the
islamic republic of iran or artesh a
traditional army with its navy air force
and army and then on the other hand
there is the revolutionary guard or
seppa and yes the iranian revolutionary
guard also has its own navy its own air
force and its own army as i've already
mentioned these are two parallel armies
independent of each other
[Music]
two armies with different commanders who
do not even agree on key issues in fact
it is not uncommon for them to hold
opposing positions
rare criticism of the irgc rooted in
iran's military rivalry the regime
instigated a nurtured rivalry between
the army and the irgc has reached a
point where it undermines the regime the
separation is such that the two armies
do not even share personnel or equipment
so that under no circumstances is a
revolutionary guard air force fighter
used by the army air force and vice
versa in fact its own evolution is also
very very different to the detriment of
the conventional army the revolutionary
guard is becoming more and more
important and powerful among other
reasons because this kind of parallel
army has a very unusual advantage it is
highly specialized in a specific type of
war that is becoming more and more
relevant and which we have already
talked about here on visualpolitik i am
referring to asymmetric warfare
[Music]
let me explain asymmetrical warfare is
by definition a type of warfare that
pits two sides with very disparate
forces against each other and that
usually never engage in direct combat it
is a type of war in which one of the two
sides is organized in guerilla units and
carries out its interventions through
covert operations small rapid strikes
and even attacks and sabotage of all
kinds we are talking about a type of
strategy for which the support of local
organizations such as tribal groups or
armed gangs is frequently sought in
other words a type of warfare that in
order to be effective requires enormous
amounts of intelligence contacts and a
very advanced knowledge of the
environment
[Music]
the point is that in practice to carry
out this type of warfare requires the
development of highly specialized
structures that are dedicated and
focused exclusively on this mission
asymmetric warfare and you know what in
the case of the iranian revolutionary
guard such a structure exists it is
known as the kudzu force this is an
elite force that i'm sure many of you
are familiar with if only because of
this new story
us kills commander of iran's elites
codes force
[Music]
we covered it here on visualpolitik the
u.s drone assassination of kasem
suleimani was a direct blow to the
ayatollah's most important military unit
it was a group famous for carrying out
all kinds of asymmetric operations
operations such as kidnappings sabotage
assassinations or also for example
training and equipping guerrillas and
paramilitary forces whose objectives
coincide with those of tehran that is
precisely the case of hezbollah hamas or
more recently the taliban themselves but
wait a minute does all this mean that
the revolutionary guard is limited to
carrying out these kinds of special
operations abroad no nothing could be
further from the truth the truth is that
this organization has a gigantic
presence in iranian politics and not
only in politics but also in the
country's own economy
[Music]
for example among other assets the
revolutionary guard directly controls
media outlets educational institutions
and even gas and oil fields in addition
thanks to the reconstruction role it was
given after the war with iraq which
ended in 1988 the revolutionary guard
was able to forge close tithes of more
than 100 construction and engineering
companies that manage capital of
approximately 12 billion all these
activities and the huge state budget
that directly or indirectly passes
through its hands make the irgc the most
powerful organization in iran
[Music]
to give you an idea an iranian dissident
who was once a co-founder of this sort
of parallel army has described it as
follows be warned
i don't know of any other organization
in any country like the revolutionary
guards it is something like the
communist party the kgb a business
complex and the mafia matzen cezara
founding member of the revolutionary
guard corps
and take note because in terms of the
number of troops the revolutionary guard
is on par with armies as important as
those of france germany or the united
kingdom
of the 523 000 active military personnel
in the islamic republic of iran 190 000
belong to the revolutionary guard of
these between 17 000 and 21 000 make up
the elite group known as the kudz force
or the cuts force that's not the end of
it in addition the revolutionary guard
also controls its own paramilitary group
known as the bassage a religious militia
made up of some six 000 people that the
revolutionary guard frequently uses to
control civil society for example to
repress demonstrations or protests
in fact it is precisely by using the
basic group that the iranian regime can
commit all sorts of barbarities such as
arbitrarily beating and arresting people
without any formal security forces
having to get their hands dirty a good
example was in 2019 during the massive
protests against the iranian regime
iran's leader ordered crackdown on
unrest do whatever it takes to end it
kameni who has ruled iran for three
decades turned to his elite forces to
put down the recent unrest the
revolutionary guards and its affiliated
bhaji religious military about 1 500
people were killed during less than two
weeks of unrest that started on november
15th the toll provided by reuters by
three iranian interior ministry
officials included at least 17 teenagers
and about 400 women as well as some
members of the security forces and
police
but well there is one question we have
to answer to what extent is it feasible
to have two armies in the same country
listen up
[Music]
a growing force
the history of the iranian revolutionary
guard is curious to say the least and it
is because their rise to power was
linked to a military fiasco
during the war that pitted the iran of
the ayatollahs against saddam hussein's
iraq during 1980 and 1988 the role of
the revolutionary guard was fundamental
you see when saddam hussein evaded iran
in september 1980 the iraqi army was one
of the most advanced professional armies
in the world the revolutionary guard on
the other hand was at that time a motley
militia of poorly trained and poorly
armed recruits remember that the islamic
revolution in iran had triumphed belly a
year earlier so the ayatollah's order to
unify professionalise and equip the
militias around the revolutionary guard
had not yet materialized to make matters
worse the national army was also in a
very precarious situation largely as a
result of internal purges and the flight
of many officers after the triumph of
the islamic revolution the result was a
disaster perhaps not the worst scenario
but a really bad one the iraqi invasion
resulted in terrible human damage
hundreds of thousands of iranian
soldiers and more than a hundred
thousand civilians died in the conflict
the point is that no one put more blood
and more martyrs on the battlefield than
the revolutionary guard and the basic
militia something that allowed ayatollah
khamenei's regime to prove that what it
had at its fingertips was an extremely
loyal group and loyalty loyalty is just
what you need when you want to
consolidate a revolution and a
tyrannical regime let's say that the
religious authorities at that precise
moment saw it very clearly they had to
have their own praetorian guard
a well-trained force specialized in all
kinds of covert operations something
like the iron fist of faith so no sooner
said than done the ayatollahs rewarded
these groups with more power more means
and more effectiveness thus while the
conventional army has continued to
protect the national borders the
ayatollahs have developed their own
shock force a force that allows them to
extend their influence beyond national
borders to control intelligence to
combat infiltration of the country by
foreign powers also if necessary to
defend the theocratic regime of course
at the end of the day influence rules
and it's clear that if your superior is
the ayatollah then you're in a better
position than those who are answering to
the president's subordinates to
religious power the result is that
throughout all these years the
revolutionary guard is gradually
displacing the armed forces of the
islamic republic as the true emblem and
reference of national security
[Music]
for example it is the revolutionary
guard and not the army that operates
most of the thousands of short and
medium-range missiles that have the
capacity to attack the heart of israel
and that today have become the main
deterrent force for the country and the
same could be said about the
incorporation of new tanks armored
vehicles and even fighter bombers it is
increasingly common for this political
military body to receive the best
resources first however their nature and
modus operandi remain exactly the same
south korean flag tanker seized by iran
see all demands release iran's
revolutionary guard course seized a
south korean flag tanker in gulf waters
and attained its crew amid tensions
between tehran and seal over iranian
funds frozen in south korean banks due
to u.s sanctions
by the way do you want to know how this
story ended well after the ship was
detained between january and april 2021
it was finally released by iran but they
didn't do it for free
iran frees south korean ship captain
after promise to help with frozen funds
iran released on friday a south korean
ship and its captain after south korea
promised to try to secure the release of
iranian funds frozen in south korean
banks under u.s sanctions
[Applause]
anyway that is the story of iran's
revolutionary guard the curious case of
a country with two armies but now it's
your turn do you think that the growing
importance of the iranian revolutionary
guard could be causing serious friction
with the armed forces of the islamic
republic what do you think of this model
of one country two armies leave us your
answer below in the comments and now if
you found this video interesting then of
course go ahead and subscribe to
visualpolitik and like the video all the
best i'll see you next time
[Music]